Kinematics is the
geometry of motion.
To simplify the motion
of a pointer finger,
the three finger bones are
modeled as narrow cylinders.
The two joints are
modeled as small spheres
each 0.1 centimeters
in diameter--
so they show this
right over here--
and rotating from the center.
The finger is mapped on a
Cartesian coordinate plane.
So here's the first joint
of the pointer finger,
and while I'm doing
this I'm actually
looking at the side of
my left pointer finger
and it's pointing straight up.
And this is what it looks like
although my-- this top section
right over here is
much longer for me.
It's much closer to
this middle section.
But anyway let's see
what they have to say.
They say the first finger
bone is 2.4 centimeters long,
which actually looks about
right for mine as well.
The middle finger bone is
2/3 the length of the first,
so that's this length
right over here.
And 2/3 of 2.4 is
going to be, what, 1.6.
So this distance right over--
if we do that in a color
we can actually see-- this
distance right over here
is 2.4 centimeters.
This distance right over
here is 2/3 of that,
so that's 1.6 centimeters.
And the top finger bone is 1/3
the length of the first, which
does seem short, but I'll
just go with their numbers.
So 1/3 of 2.4 , this
is 0.8 centimeters--
everything we're doing
is in centimeters.
The center of the
tip of the finger
goes from open at 0.5-- so
that point right over there--
to a closed fist.
So when the fist is closed--
and I'm looking at my hand
doing it right over
here-- the finger
will look something like
this-- the pointer finger.
And so the tip
goes to x comma y.
They want us to figure out
the x-coordinate of x comma y.
So maybe we don't even have to
worry about the y-coordinate.
So let me draw this
a little bit larger
just so that we can
make sense of it.
So we have this first
section of the finger.
It's 2.4.
So this is 2.4 centimeters and
it's completely horizontal.
I'll try to draw it
as large as I can
so that we can make
sense of all of this.
So that right over there
is 2.4 centimeters.
And then it hits this joint.
This joint has a radius-- or has
a diameter of 0.1 centimeters.
So it's radius right over
there is 0.05 centimeters.
So the entire length of this
section you see here is 2.45.
So this point right over
here is at 2.45 comma 0.
Then you have the
next section, which
has a length of 1.6
centimeters, and they
tell us this is a
45 degree angle.
So this right over here
is 1.6 centimeters.
And of course you have
that 0.05 radius again.
So this entire length
is going to be 1.65.
But then we have
another joint here
which we can't forget about.
We have this joint
right over here.
So let's draw that.
So you have this
joint right over here.
Draw it.
It has a diameter
of 0.1 centimeters,
and I'm definitely not
drawing this joint to scale.
I'm just trying to make sure
we pay attention to the joint.
So let me draw a
little bit better.
Something like this.
And once again we
have another 0.5.
So this entire length, if we
were to go from this center
to that center, is
going to be 1.6.
Plus these two radii, which
add up to 0.1 diameter,
which is going to
be plus 0.1 which
is equal to 1.7 centimeters.
So this entire side
is 1.7 centimeters.
This entire side is 2.45.
So plus 0.05 is equal to 2.45.
And then finally
this last section--
we have a right angle here.
They tell us that
this is a right angle.
And this section right
over here is 0.8.
This is going to be--
let me make it clear--
so this section
right over here--
if we don't count
the joint--is 0.8.
But then we have of course
this 0.05 centimeters.
So plus 0.05 you get this
whole length right over here.
I don't want to clutter it.
This whole length to
the tip right is 0.857.
Now how do we figure out the
coordinate of this thing?
And I encourage you to
pause the video at any time
to try to figure
out this and really
just to save us work
let's see if we can just
focus on the x-squared.
And I'm just going try to come
up with an expression for it.
I don't feel like using
my calculator just now.
So the first thing is, let's try
to figure out an x-coordinate.
Let's try to figure out the
x-coordinate for that point
right over there.
So where does that point
intersect the x-axis?
So essentially what is this
distance right over here?
What's going to be 2.45 minus
whatever this distance is?
And we should be able to
use this distance given
the fact that this
is a 45 degree angle.
We know this length
right over here,
and this is a right triangle.
We could use a little
bit of trigonometry.
We know that the cosine--
relative to this angle
this is the hypotenuse
and this side is adjacent.
So we know the
cosine of 45 degrees
is equal to the length
of the adjacent side.
So let's say that's what
we're trying to figure out.
Let's just say that's
going to be a for adjacent.
Now let me do this in a color
that I haven't used yet.
So it's going to be equal
to the length of that side A
over the length
of the hypotenuse.
Over adjacent, over hypotenuse.
The hypotenuse we already
figured out is 1.7 centimeters.
Or we could say that a is equal
to 1.7 times the cosine of 45
degrees.
That's this length.
So if you wanted this
x-coordinate right over here,
that x-coordinate is going
to be this x-coordinate,
which is 2.45 minus a.
So minus 1.7 times the
cosine of 45 degrees-- and we
don't know what the y-coordinate
is we haven't figured that out.
But the question doesn't ask us
to.-- But let's see if we can
just, going with
the x-coordinates,
if we can get all the way to
this x-coordinate right over
here.
Well this x-coordinate, is that
x-coordinate right over there.
And so let's see, if we
can figure out this length,
we could subtract that
length from this x-coordinate
and get to this x-coordinate.
And how can we figure
out that length?
Well that length's going to be
the same thing as this length
down here.
And this is a completely
a horizontal line.
So this is going to be parallel
to that line over there.
If you view this as
a transversal of two
parallel lines if this angle
is 45 degrees I'm running out
of colors here-- if this
angle is 45 degrees,
then this angle is also
going to be 45 degrees.
If this is a right angle,
which it is, that's a 90--
so then this is going to
have to be 45 as well.
Because 45 plus 90 plus 45
are going to be 180 degrees.
We've gone completely round.
We're forming a
completely straight line.
So this is a 45 degree angle.
How do we figure out this
length right over here?
Well once again, the
cosine of 45 degrees
is going to be equal to the
length of the adjacent side,
which is what we
want to figure out.
We don't want-- it I know
this thing's getting messy--
We want to figure out this
length right over here.
It's going to be equal--
let's call that length x--
it's going to be equal to x over
the length of the hypotenuse.
That's what this 0.85 is.
So that 0.85, that is the
hypotenuse right there.
And my apologies
for this messiness.
0.85.
Or we get x is equal to 0.85
times the cosine of 45 degrees.
So that's this length
right over here.
So if we want this
x-coordinate right over here,
we just subtract this
distance from this distance.
So the x-coordinate--
that's what
the whole problem's
going to be about.
The x-coordinate is going
to be-- let me just write it
in one color-- 2.45 minus
1.7 times the cosine of 45
degrees minus this.
Minus 0.85 times the
cosine of 45 degrees.
And so this is going
to be equal to-- we
deserve a drum
roll-- this is going
to be equal to 2.45 minus--
what is this-- 2.55 times
the cosine of 45 degrees.
That's going to be
the x-coordinate.
And we don't know what
the y-coordinate is,
but all they asked us
for is the x-coordinate.